bonjour bonjour et bienvenue à agen 2016
championnat de france est bien pour la
deuxième fois consécutive on reçoit le
grand maître marty et français bien
entendu
yannick gozzoli auter hauteur
aujourd'hui d'une superbe partie
intégrante et comptant comme amiens
ouais je suis assez soulagé parce que
tigran il me marche dessus littéralement
ces dernières années donc du coup
c'était après la fois que je le battais
et les verts j'avais une cuisante
défaite à la ronde 9 way qui m'avait
totalement éliminé de la course au titre
et donc du coup c'est bon c'était déjà
pas vraiment de pression mais bon je
voulais quand même battre alors c'est un
gros client d'autant que si le
vice-champion en titre ont travaillé
sortant siemens annoncent leur terrible
il est très solide et très difficile à
battre
très peu mais il a montré aux quais qui
n'était pas totalement en forme pour le
but justement parce qu'il a quand même
fait nul à la première ronde rec et
blanc jean françois joly bien que ce ne
soit pas chose facile de gagner contre
jean-françois on a l'exemple mais ok
quand même une différence et il a fait
nul à la ronde de sang vous et je pense
contre sébastien feller donc ils avaient
les blancs en plus cela donc comme il
est avait battu l'an dernier
psychologiquement c'est peu c'est pas
facile
ouais mais honnêtement
j'avais pas de pression particulière et
parce que j'étais content d'avoir gagné
hier et pour le tournoi contre ces
bassins particulier mais de mettre un
point cependant l'a dit on est important
et donc et ça donne la confiance donc
j'étais assez en confiance même si
j'étais pas tous assez satisfait par mon
jeu et aujourd'hui je me suis préparé
sérieusement
malheureusement je me suis retrouvé à
dove book assez rapidement mais bon je
me suis débrouillé
on va voir ça à cette belle partie alors
tu allais nord donc on met la position
côté noir c'est vrai et du mal et c'est
parti donc que quatre dont tu
t'attendais à ça ils oublient souvent
oui oui jouer exclusivement le cas ces
dernières années donc ça c'est une
petite surprise pour lui mais ça va pas
surpris vraiment je jouais au 5 juin
l'espagnol donc il a contré dès le début
un ouais mais ça n'a pas surpayé
particulièrement ici attendent et je
pense d'un cross qu'il a joué très vite
les coups ou suivant donc avec trois des
six est là il faut bien sûr des cinq
essais il joue exclusivement ça aussi
c'est de naw d'accord là c'est pardon tu
as joué ça exprès tu pensais qu'ils
allaient jouer ça on verra
c'est ça le truc en fait d'accord mais
je me suis mis à quai j'aime bien
changer régulièrement je teste aucun
truc et je suis là pour m'amuser donc je
me suis dit bon ce qui est toujours une
bonne stratégie parce que oui final on
joue mieux quand on prend plaisir un
ouais c'est sûr tout ça désinhibe le
fait de jouer des positions nouvelles
c'est à dire que comme j'ai une position
je suggère de réfléchir tout de suite si
je répète pas ma préparation
oui et donc du coup comme c'est très
nouveau pour moi bah je m'amuse quoi
gagner 17
donc ça s'est joué à andorre à la
dernière ronde j'avais déjà affronté
cette ouverture est
j'avais fait une partie correcte aussi
donc du coup j'ai répété
mais là il m'a surpris il a joué des
quatre quelque chose qui la fait très
rarement ces dernières années lacan
parce que normalement ils jouent plutôt
petit rock d'abord avec céline critique
petit rock à six coups des trois
d'accord il ya des battues au plus haut
niveau il faut des 3 avant de jouer des
4 way gens ces trois ans ces deux et
ensuite déclaré voilà et donc du coût
des quatre ça a pour avantage de prendre
de l'espace tout de suite et surtout
poser des questions la structure de noir
c'est hier qu'est ce qu'on va placer
comme pièce et comment on va les mettre
donc j'ai pris on l'a prise normale
il a un bon bilan de la dame puisque
comme le cavalier peut pas venir en c6
la dame est tranquille voilà et puis
prendre l'espace et surtout qu'il peut
me mettre une pression sur l'option de 6
parce que simon mois question ça va tu
dois savoir comment je passe mes pions
au centre ouais donc si je mets mes
pions aussi cédé 6 le plan de 6 points
faibles si je mets pion aux 5es des six
le pion de 6 sera arriérés sur lacaune
overdrive et suit en plus la casse des 5
sera un super tremplin pour cette pièce
oui donc du coup j'ai joué à boire à 6
c'est là encore si je crois que c'est
normal donc là ça nous oblige à prendre
une décision sur le fou ils auraient pu
revenir il ya natacha m'amuse mandat là
je me fous de rage au choix de sophie
pas très bien réagi
si tu peux de bêtises will et elle s'est
retrouvée un peu moins bien mais
peut-être que je vois ça j'ai
l'impression en tout cas mais voilà tous
les moyens à ces trucs donc un peu chaud
donc elle appuie la coquetterie grana
prises quelques normal vous prend et là
il ya deux écoles et à l'école classique
on vous petit rock et l'école
on vit cela casse donc on joue ces
quatre c'est grave c'est que oui alors
c'est un peu logique on se disait avec
manuel parce que happy c'est là mais
quand commenté la partie en direct
bien sûr il ya les taux de maroussi avec
en plus le foot a été changée puisque
son souffle derrière ses pions n'est pas
forcément très actif et il peut coûter
cher sauf une et il peut coûter cher
c'est vrai qu'en finale après ça peut ça
s'est passé dans la partie donc on y va
donc j'ai joué cavalier ci soit la
légère a tous bluffés à partir de là
parce que j'avais que des bribes de
souvenirs de deux variantes
oui justement rappelé que cariat qui
n'avait joué contre ce vide lors la
coupe du monde un peu en base 2g si ce
qui m'avait plu décidemment joue le
cavalier la belle a par exemple
caillaissé 3g 6
ouais mais sauf que quand je jouais qu'à
bercy je me suis posé la question d'un
coup et je me suis mais si je vous
faisais ça qu'est ce que je fais et
c'est ce qu'il a fait et oui les cinq et
il a commencé à beaucoup réfléchir déjà
parce que je crois que pour je faisais
ça qu'il a pris beaucoup de temps
ouais et donc et c'est ça je pense que
c'est ce qui lui a coûté la partie c'est
qu'il a pris énormément de temps à des
moments importants
mais il s'est retrouvé très vite en
design hot wheels ouais j'ai décidé de
jouer aussi si si mais j'ai pas peur de
kim doublé pions parce qu'évidemment la
paire de faux va être très forte et j'ai
le pire c'est qu'à doit se retrouver
très désavantage parce que maintenant je
pouvoir l'attaquer frontalement et pour
s'éviter bessin pour ces huit baies
scène plus tard la main si le canadien
c'est renseigne robles changer les dames
menzies a doublé ce n'est les pions
c'est pas très grave mais le fou sera
davantage son long terme donc les joues
énormes à lille avec et ses trois fosses
phone 7 mais là j'étais surpris vers 500
mètres ça va beaucoup surpris oui alors
là on s'est dit c'est ce que c'est pas
un peu prématuré est effectivement sm il
ya beaucoup de choix je m'aventurerais
pas à dire ce qu'il faut faire ou pas
faire parce que j'en ai aucune idée
mais en fait j'avais l'intention de
donner le plan des systèmes beaucoup de
lignes pour faire [ __ ] en c3 c6
derrière et jouer contre les fiancés qui
sont faibles et
bon je pense que les noirs sont ok mais
honnêtement j'y connais rien je crois
j'ai pas de souvenir de reviers plus
sûres comme ça la plage était vraiment
on l'a prise et obliger un oui oui prix
c'est normal et là la question il ya
beaucoup de questions possibles il ya
beaucoup de coups possibles après
cavaliers province ainsi qu'à l'étranger
mais je pense que j'ai joué un coup
intéressant ces dames c est au début je
voulais je dame s'est vite parce que
dame 7 me faisais pas à cause de faux f4
oui il est sûre le soutenir avec alaric
une attaque sur la dame voilà en fait je
le sentais venir à ces cinq sans doute
non oui c'est possible mais davos est
justement c'est mon idée c'est de voir
éventuellement je donne ces cinq voix là
et je me suis dit que surfe le f4 en
plus j'ai d'autres coups ces stations
sont forgés ça qui me gêne
- est-ce que si je joue ou passivement
part si je joue rock oui il va faire
pareil va faire d'un match qui va faire
rock aussi la fin des matchs 4 way et il
va jouer tour ou un tour 3 pour g3 wave
asn le mater comme cela avait il dit a
peur que ça aille trop vite quoi ouais
il faut donc du coup je me suis déjà
prêt dames c'est cette ils sont fous
rires en f4 je suis content parce qu'ils
ne croient plus et la lame de plus que
s'arrachent date oui d'accord oui cela
le frustre et menaçants sur la dame etc
mais il a réfléchi là il a réfléchi
c'est colossal ouais je crois qu'il a
réfléchi on avait une demi heure on
avait affiché une demi heure chacun ce
moment là et là il a réfléchi quelque
chose comme une trente minutes c'est
beaucoup
cela commença à oui là ça commence à
peser la loge noire est assez simple
donc au moins je vois beaucoup de
questions à me poser et j'ai juste à
placer les pièces alors que c'est ici
mis la pression tout seul aussi congés
entre logique et là alors là on s'est
dit
oui pourquoi pas tour des huit tout de
suite aussi j'ai pensé autour de jeux de
suite mais on va le voir en vo mais ma
vraie tour arrivé un peu tôt mais en
fait ce que j'ai joué ça propose un
piège un petit piège cinq sens où ces
six qu'il a joué tour à tour et feu un
mail à h61 coûte très très embêtant si
oui certeurope pâte aptitude à bord en
âge si c'est parce que je veux pas qu'il
va notamment acheter
tapez 1 tapez s'ils se montrent une
attaque à la marque à tour trois tours
age iii est très difficile de parer une
attaque sur le rang 1
c'est ça donc du coup insiste je pense
le fou à partir et le fupo personnes
pour tous parce que la loi que je vous
offre 4 par exemple à l'état soit s'il
avait joué c'est parce qu'il a fait mais
admettons mais il joue aussi du post
détient 6 g km uh 5g tour de huit pardon
demandé huit tours des huit d'abord qui
attaquent la dame
ouais d'accord ok bon il peut faire des
coups aussi mesdames e3 semble beaucoup
plus normal et la cave à jazz funk et
maintenant camélia chiens et à l'oeuf ou
ne peut pas à rester sur la diagonale
voilà et si je veux corriger si l'on
fait éliminer même tu va l'éliminer
je le prends sans eux il faut le prendre
avec une bonne position puisque
évidemment finale talent avantage parce
que tu auras un fou au moins fou quand
on sait à peu près équilibrés pendant
ces six là il peut prendre ceci je
voulais danser si tu vas prendre quelque
chose si je prends un quatrième ronde au
8 avril à calais où il faut reprendre
avec la dame est d'accord et dans ce cas
là le fou pour revenir en
sans doute en l'air trop d'accord c'est
un peu près équilibré
c'est par ailleurs la seule à la place
de ça ils pouvaient jouer surtout h4 le
problème qu'il a joué c'est surtout h4
mélanger tour des huit donc tourner vite
qui est un très bon coin avant de
croquer d'ailleurs parce que c'est un
giro qui est très tard tarot qui est
très tard oui mais là j'avais beaucoup
de la libération ses cages et 4g
longtemps oui c'est un super beau coup
qu'avais-je éclate parce que là on se
dit aux joueurs je dirais
comme moi on a envie de rock et
maintenant parce que c'est fini et il
faut jouer débarrasse d'abord de la
pression et oui oui parce qu'à une
pression parce qu'on s'est dit siroki
afu g3 qui est pénible
oui mais sa chance parce que je donne
ces huit ans je suis noir sont ok ouais
c'est vrai mais c'est un peu noël c'est
un peu désagréable
alors que laquelle et g4 sa leader il ya
ici alors il ya une menace aussi sur 7
oui parce qu'il ya car les premiers sets
on va prendre un pro 6 échecs et on se
dit c'est ouais donc il faut faire gaffe
quoi donc qu'elle g4 et les options il a
pris ce qui est pas le seul coup et il a
fait une erreur de calcul terrain aussi
loin qu il y avait deux hommes g3 qui
étaient possibles alors dame g3 est
d'alger 3 j'avais si je dis pas de
bêtises qu'ils allaient prendre cinq
cavaliers princesse morissette
il a larger il peut prendre s'ils
préfèrent alors pour prendre 5
s'intéressant aussi la fin d'un certain
sens c'est fou tout reprendre le projet
cette île peut pas d'un cross check call
il revient le g6 protéger les autres il
veut faire tourcoing au 5 et en fait
mais nous on ne gagne mon option que
noir gagne à cause de fourrage top four
1 6 4 mais il ya tout reproche et c'est
pourquoi aussi je crois un miroir de 7
ha oui tout reprend 2,6 et la dame
attaque la dame
bien sûr durant aussi ses droits de
saucisses ici sur roy 17 efforcés de
protéger la dame puisque la dame ici
attaque la dame mais c'est bien sinon
tout de suite de jets une pièce en fait
il a damé attaquer donc qu'il soit s'il
prend la dame je fais roi prend pour
apprendre et à une pièce de plus j'ai
une pièce de plus mais j'ai un autre
coup aussi c'est qu'à la place de jouer
vous prend h4 je peux jouer g5 alors à
temps et c'est ici au lieu de [ __ ] en
hqe est il ya aussi à huy g5 qui on
ferme le full black eagle le fou sur
place
j'ai 5 et le fou est complètement coincé
devrait donc donc ça gagne il a joué et
l étranger cup donc à l'étranger car
hélas il y avait d'autres coups aussi
sodome g3 excuse moi à te dire ici sur
elle dit prévoir un truc c'est que sur
câble d'alger trois caves et des ponts
de singe ils doivent peu avant tout
prendre sept fous prononcer mais là j'ai
un gros coup intermédiaire voyez ces
canaux directs 3g pour casser ces
structures kf3 est devenu champion prend
si on prend de changer d'homme en
échange les dames dont parle bien sûr
dans prend h franc côté droit prend le
set avec une bonne partie des heureuses
pour des jeux puis on rêve déjà d'autres
les objets plus ou moins de joseph 4f
cadre ombragé 2 c'est pas bon c'est dr
oui autour des 3 kiki oui c'est pas
beaucoup de nos d'abord autour des 3
prévus et donc s4 et ce en voilà mais la
maman elle et m avec h 5 h 4 déjà et
peut [ __ ] le match 5 h 4 pour ouvrir à
l'école ah oui il ya en plus avec le
fouquet là ça fait maths mais aussi tout
simplement jeu autour des deux est
tourné huit moines l'arrêt de la
colonisation est bien supérieur aux
cavaliers sa dette avantage pour les
morts tout à fait d'accord
donc il a fait cas des projets 4g cuir
en h cup
et là il a fait une énorme erreur en
l'as poulx prend 1,4 mais déjà ici on se
dit c'est eagle l'événement aussi peu
mieux résolus l'ouverture ils ont quand
même deux fous contre de carélie même si
elle peut en prendre
voilà celui là il peut être pris quand
tu peux comprendre eux mais il reste 1
quand même et le caractère déséquilibré
de la structure de pions favorise les
fous c'est à dire que dans l'amant les
cavaliers sont supérieures sont ils fous
ce super qu'avait dit quand la structure
allait oui elle est asymétrique et là
toutes les finales vont être super pour
moi donc je suis assez confiant a dit
oui là il traque parce qu'il est trop
confiant je pense qu'ils savaient déjà
qu'ils n'étaient pas bien mais la fois
une maladie rare la partie mais le
problème c'est que
à tenter quelque chose il a tenté un
truc et surtout ils pensaient que
il n'a pas réussi à se dire je vais
essayer de tenir la finale quoi
finalement
ben il peut jouer cavalier au sein qui
s'y plonger caballos elle pourrait
légaliser fini le fou et jouer à la base
il est sûr c'est qu'elle est reprise de
temps donc il a essayé de jouer leur
va-tout donc il a joué quatre des cinq
et justement c'est là qu'il a juste peur
de rien et raconte j'ai pris là
simplement fou prend qui on prend et
tour prends tu as gagné un pion bavent
la partie n'est pas finie et c'est la
suite va être quand même super man ray
j'ai essayé d'être assez précis pour
l'empêcher de là je me suis simplement
qu'après tour c1 c'est ce qu'il a fait
il ya des mauvais 3d possible aussi mais
jurassien qui donne des mythes sur jeu
sur côté toutes les portes les pièces
as-tu double ici sur la colonne aussi
des salades à la casse des deux qui est
quand même vu aussi bien sûr damas 7 et
là je me suis dit au pire j'ai petit
rock et après petit roeulx que les noirs
sont très très bien parce que je la tour
qui est magnifique on fouquet supérieur
aux cavaliers il a pas d'organisation
way est en fait c'est là j'ai commencé à
réfléchir quand même si qui est
peut-être plus précis je pense que fufu
g5 et plus pesé c'est très beau sous les
5 c'est un très joli coup mais très
précis parce que qu'au fond les blancs
c'est pas facile si on enlève cette tour
il ya sans doute une attaque sur la
première rangée et donc oui ou voilà
pourquoi et si je joue cavalier ou trois
je prends juste quant au 3e tour de
cette je conserve mon tour datent de
plus oui oui mais surtout jour tu sais
pas ce qu'ils peuvent faire ça à chaud
comme j'aime mes jambes parce que celui
de ça aussi mon village à tourbes et un
bon alors du coup c'est un aveu de
l'erreur parce que du coup effectivement
là cette tour qui sortait des gains de
temps finalement elle sort pas et là
c'est cette dame c'est un truc super
dames et c7 la hauteur je protège ma
case au sol et je protège l'entrée on
peut pas revenir avec le cavalier on
protège 17
et cette dame commence à avoir des
problèmes parce qu'elle peut pas sortir
non c'était intéressés commencent à
naître un petit m2 shon 15 h théâtre là
j'aurais dû prendre simplement
ouais on peut prendre en l'ajout d'un
bref quatre ans mais c'est fini on
prendre plus d'un mètre cannes mais
c'est pas mal ce que tu as choisie et
surtour seul jeu de mettre cap et
légumes c'est un échec ans et lui tend
de 8 mais je mets une pièce en de 8,4
attaque le cavalier voilà puis après
tout mais je me suis dit que fout des
lieux semblaient plus forte quand je
vous dis déjà morts soit madame x sa
foulée 6 pour voir si ça bien peu
d'intérêt ce coup ci la donne tout fou
de foot et de aussi tu désorganise le
sait-on il sait pas trop où aller
et comme cette dame nana na pas de na
pas de case il ya des menaces des
terrains à base de foie 5-fu b6 et la
dame est éperdu donc ça c'est ça fait
peur quand même le sol autour d'eux et
oui hélas gérera qu'est ce qui peut
faire nôtre sera aussi parce que s'ils
jouent autour des 1
si je vous la torgnole au tour jouera
jamais donc qu'il est obligé de faire
tours 2 mais là j'ai réfléchi longuement
parce que je pensais que donnent ces cas
de gagner tout de suite oui
alors voilà alors le problème ah oui
mais alors ça on l'avait vu la halle
segel sa cavale et de 3,6 alors je pense
que dans ces cas attaque double surtout
ricard a eu lieu 3 alors on peut faire
cavalier de 3 ses obligés d'en france 2
qu'elle prend 2,5 e prend 2,5 de calais
prend des cinq de prendre des séries à
la fin il ya un objet vie 3g full dame
de vite c'est d'apprendre je suis tfou
d'un prince fuite
et maintenant tu dis faut un avec ya une
menace de matisse à anne hathaway
mais j'ai pas vu le gain ben justement
des projets cette saga c'est sûr parce
que sur d'un projet cette méga me prend
il y a
comment ça marchait dame en bref deux
ans pour ses jolies ces géométriques
adam prend 1,22 d'impro h 4 fev de
charleroi avant ya morte
atx 2 dimpre entame proie g192 fou et ce
deux roues en f1
cette décote est maintenant et je laisse
mater je tacle odom et yahia rien
n'aurait pas défense parce que s'il fait
tout richet comprend la tour d'en
prendre on apprend et à la fin je
ramasse la dame guèye mais il faut le
voir ça c'est quand même joli mais
j'avais vu ce truc là mais après il y en
avait une autre c'est qu'il est pas
obligé de jouer ça sur foot et de rugby
8 c'est ça ça me gênait parce que ok bon
je peux avoir une fille elle avait
complètement délirante un tu peux jouer
les dames prend un f2 voilée d'un
problème de la broye h1h1 d'emprunt hkd
alors si par exemple il fait dommage de
je pose juste échangé les dames et j'ai
trop peur pour son fils âgé que trop
bien pour la vérité ouais mais si non
c'est avec le coeur des passes et
c'était très facile à gagner
pas de problème mais on va j'ai
simplement je lui disais comment je
gagne cette position il n'y a pas de
magouilles à base de fouet au faubourg
après non je voyais pas de gain de
concret donc je me suis dis plutôt que
lui donner des chances quand je vais
garder les pièces sur le gg ouais
et qu'est-ce que je joue à la place je
veux tu retires hoc
voilà je me suis dit le jeu vers ok je
me dis c'est très très fort parce que eh
bien tu peux doubler et tripler
et puis la dame toujours pas bougé et le
risque se faire prendre tout le temps 3
et là je pense que j'ai commencé un
petit peu pataugé à la table j'ai voulu
trouver un gain en force
ouais et j'ai pas trouvé donc ça m'a
fait un petit peu c'est pour détroit est
très fort pour détroit très ferme sur
tour des 3 tu sûr contrôler les casses
de sortie de la dame c'est à dire qu'il
peut plus bouger du tout du tout du
c'était mon idée tour des trois et non
seulement on peut éventuellement prendre
3 quand l'occasion se présente mais
c'est tout on enlève les cases de sortie
aussi de la menace assez pénible et joue
le veuilles ou piché tout le coup
suivant b4y gérer 4 à 6 ans il faut
expliquer parce que là sinon comprends
pas qu'ils seront reclassés ça je laisse
fois c'est un coup voilà je la trouvais
4e le fou menace de venir ici en assène
puis en d6 et la dame éprise donc le
coût des quatre il n'est pas là pour
gagner de l'espace saint gildas non mais
vous oubliez cette idée mais ça empêche
le fou de venir attaquer la dame voilà
c'est un coup de défense bizarrement et
c'est pas un coup facile à trouver
non non c'est pas facile mais il a joué
très vite entre les poteaux sourire pas
vraiment le choix
c'est bon ils étaient voit qu'il est
désorganisée parce que ce fou la coupe
complètement la communication trop
ciblée est ce ça fait peur et notamment
alors il y avait aussi des possibilités
sur tours d un homme simplement son rang
après la dame est attaquée donc il faut
reprendre et la tour est perdu de sa
démarche en fait non je voulais garder
la tour la colonne des ailes à moi et là
on se dit la position c'est une position
de rêve mais encore faut-il à
transformer mon envoi des prêts cela
c'est en fait j'ai stressé un petit peu
mais en fait c'est assez facile à
transformer surtout qu'il a mise à damas
m en 11 endroits donc camille f1 mais je
faisais trois pouces et 3 attend sur la
menace food et 4 et la dame n'est perdu
mais il faut absolument faire quelque
chose et là je donne c'est ce à quoi
tous ces deux heures de balade encore
les emplois sur le fou là j'ai pas été
cette fois ci j'ai joué dans 17 je crois
qu'il prenne mieux tu peut etre pas le
meme f4 dams et 4 dames
je n'ai pas les chiffres de champion de
cette soul et donner aucune chance
d'accord donc aux up down 17 pour garder
le contrôle sur 17 et en menacent
toujours fous des quatre dames ces cinq
dames ces cinq là cette fois donc où
fritzl enfin s'échapper
ouais mais non comme un vecteur vie dans
ce fouillis magnifique en d4 puisque tu
visage de suffisent bien sur f2
notamment bon ceci il ya le cavalier
femmes et on se dit des fois même si on
bouge le pion j'ai bon ben il obtient on
ne peut pas vraiment mais bon y'a le
cavalier mais elle a joué beaucoup parce
que si je vous donne ses 4 je pensais
juste jouer au foot b6 et il ya la
pression avis sur f2 est rivé sur les
épis le fou est magnifique en v6 parce
qu'il ya une attaque à blain tout en
ayant une magnifique villa jouer damas
la massane concours en transe et 7 mai
l'envoi des justes jésus se vide pour ce
8e donc la nage et puis que la colonne
et je lui pique la première rangée en
fait c'est ça le problème tour s'est
vite avec elle l'idée de pénétrer dans
le camp dans le camp ennemi
c'est pas facile parce que où va la tour
si je n'échange pas si elle vient à eux
2 par exemple
c'est ce qu'il a fait voilà donc c'est
ce qu'il a fait est là après de la
séquence j'avais vu la séquence jusqu'à
l'on est d'accord mais je suis pas sûr
c'est qu'elle soit correct mais je pense
que c'est un jeu c'est bien c'est
correct sauf s'ils s'attaquent h cup elf
six mois dit il va rentrer sur la
première rangée h4 est attaqué puis en
même temps maintenant on on reconnecte
les la tour et l'adami si les mecs mais
le g3 ici au g3 est tournée et
maintenant autour des 1 voilà avec
pénétration c'est dire que la menace
soit on défend la première rangée en
attaque sur la deuxième soit bas soit on
prend et puis parce que là si l'asse la
première rangée
c'est là bas c'est la catastrophe du
taux plein ici donc je prends bien ou si
j'avais vu quand j'ai joué tour de
france hélas très précis dam des trois
ce qui est très bien et dam des trois
c'est quand on va leur mettre le front
des 4 l'avaient la dame est devant on ne
peut pas clouer le fou et on contrôle
toutes les cases coincé si la variation
est parfaite
ouais super bien tadam en a 5 et par le
cavaliere la fin tu t'es fait le f2 très
faible ça c'est un enjeu encore lui
défend mais elle prend le nom et les
gens pas la bonne cause puisqu'il faut
défendre f2 il faut défendre d'eux et
ils les font pas grand chose mais ouais
c'est la fois que la toile d'environ 80
cas en cas de feu des cartes qui défend
quand même j 3 parce qu'il ya aussi à
lloret g3 cléac'h est heureux c'est ce
qu'il a fait céder 4 je me lasse d'un f3
la creg tavers froissé me lasser ou même
succès 2-1 on tour ces deux c'est
pénible aussi oui j'y vais d'amel froid
tu vois des chevaux de troie parce que
tu fous cavés le 3 je mange et tais je
vais faire plus on fera un ami parce que
sinon il ya trop riches est clair la
survie du matin là donc il y avait deux
ou trois quatre ans donc là j'ai pris là
le plus simple oui oui ça les revers en
fait c'est le meilleur coût oui ça gagne
tremblant là c'est la fin c'est
magnifique voyez comme c'est une
question d'activités là ici à rien si on
prend du plomb c'est la catastrophe
parce qu'il ya sans doute là madame
bello attaque là tout de suite tour ces
deux puits ces matrices sur la deuxième
rangée et en cas de toux reprend c'est
ce qui était fait maintenant c'est
l'invasion finale tour si riche et j'ai
mis un peu de temps à voir un truc parce
que ce rouage 2 mg clp 1 d'âme des uns
c'est le bon coup et n'ont pas d'âme et
fun parce que d'amener 8 md 3 voilà sûr
sinon il ya eu dans mes chèques
voilà d'amd 3 et chez l'homme et sein
chez les dames ici plus de ça il
s'appelle aussi parce que pour ces deux
ouais mais c'est quand même ces
rencontres jouées croissaient annoncé ba
s'avère pas parce qu'un tour de 7 mai au
moins voilà donc du coup il a joué g4
qu'est le sujet date pour se désoler à
120,6 nancy matin un chien minella j'ai
réfléchi parce que j'ai cherché un match
fort c'est vraiment parce que j'ai mis
du temps à voir c'est que ce roi h 3 rue
des 4 et à f/5 en fait oui les rails
bloquait bien sûr j'ai mis du temps à
voir 100 m est sûre si les blancs jouent
au raf trompeuse joue à cinq ou six sans
doute mais f5 et sans doute encore oui
les mêmes même tour ce cadre de gagner
enfin tout donner pour la tienne c'est
mieux parce que même en cas d'échec il
carrière le pion les voilà tous les
éléments qu'il a le g4 shekari là j'ai
pris mon temps pour retrouver le bien
mais d'alger un camp mais ce que j'ai
joués je pense que ça gagne pour eux et
c'est le mieux d'alger 1 c'est plus
simple parce que si on va limiter le
pion f2 donc à plus du tout des fois la
roja jeu trois épreuves de voile à damas
trois d'un point de terminer à élaborer
parce que si fait échec échec alors
c'est le seul coup à l' échec s'agissait
d'hommes des trois élèves savent pas
qu'ils les lives et là il me laisse si
je sais ce que je dois me 4 qui par le
maître mais j'ai f5 exactement qui
empêche de la dame venir en vigueur et
qui veulent astoria matin à la fcm ne
peut pas venir à la dame 1 4 qui
protégerait la case achat tout en parant
l'échec et en cas de prise
évidemment mathémat et on peut le
montrer comme ils ont à venir les dames
3 jusqu'à tours et aux proches capable
ici
roy chez 4 et toi tu rends et h théâtre
échec et mat alors on n'est pas allés
jusque là il a abandonné sur sodome
preuve de sourdun prend f2 dans une
partie donc quand même superbe parce que
c'est avec les noirs oui oui non mais je
suis content parce que c'était
nécessaire pour inattendue et puis c'est
un poids une attente mais c'est un
poignet temps du satin fait quand même 2
et 2 et demi sur trois et que vous êtes
plus que deux à être en tête puisque
mathieu cornette aussi l'a emporté même
ça va vite
voilà ouais mais c'est alors il ya moins
de monde aussi que l'an dernier puisque
vous êtes que dix joueurs et 29 élus et
donc c'est bien quoi c'est un bon départ
mon os x et de phage d'essayer de me
qualifier encore bien sûr et puis le
plus vite
je certifie voilà s'est qualifié c'est à
dire tu dis finir dans les cinq premiers
afin d'être sûr d'être réembauchés en
quelque sorte la déjà plein de choses
possible et d'ailleurs mais deux points
et demi de me garantissent pas du tout
client quel sens on a vu jean marc
d'autres à blandain voilà donc le
tournoi est long
y a pas de journée de repos va falloir
bien gérer la fatigue j'ai un gros gros
match demain contre le champion en titre
contre question est bien revenue là
d'ailleurs je fais mien que ces deux
partis parce que c'est les deux parties
que j'ai perdu la dernière canton tigres
en aide et oui c'est pour cent et donc
du coup psychologiquement j'étais un peu
un peu tendue hier mais en fait ça
allait parce que je me suis bloqué de
façon à ce qu une partie d'échecs faut
voir ce qu'on peut faire
puis ouais mais bon alors tu as tout
ceux des marseillais artois la voile je
suppose l'espère je crois que tout a été
fouillé il ya du monde qui me soutient
mais il était dit on a eu de très bonnes
ambiances à l'apparat l'appartement
transcende way à la maison c'était des
petites soirées tranquilles et ont
peut-être le matin on travaille un petit
peu et ben façon on est encore loin du
très très loin du anyama fera en fera un
bilan après la reconduite là je te dirai
ouais d'accord peut-être que je serai
plus ici du tout après on peut oui bon
compte mais j'y prends goût et la saveur
que ça s'est bien passé
j'aimerais mieux enfin l'équipe que tu
nous as de solliciter le problème c'est
que bon je pense que vous avez reçus à
mon pote tous d'accord oui mais voilà
c'est ça c'est d'ailleurs face à la
fatigue est gérée et comme j'ai pas
l'expérience
je voulais tourner comme ça très souvent
je sais qu'à un moment je vends un coup
de fatigue mais si ce moment là qu'il
faudra gérer puis on essaiera de faire
mieux que la jungle super super merci
beaucoup yanick jean pris un deuxième à
deuxième fois sur subie à gonaté vais
deux fois de suite mais il est en tête
il est en tête du national 2016 et c'est
mérité voilà merci de nous avoir suivis
c'est vraiment une belle partie je crois
si une partie a étudié dans les écoles
elle et elle est magnifique elle est
belle à voir aller elle est superbement
conclu
et voilà c'est la preuve qu'il faut
faire attention à part faire un peu
n'importe quoi au début voilà merci et à
bientôt sur diagonale tv au revoir